what is free speech is it the same as
being able to say anything without
repercussions
oh it depends what you mean by
repercussions so uh
if by repercussions you mean that the
state can arrest you
uh and lock you up or fine you or you
can be uh harassed threatened
intimidated uh
pushed out of your job then no those are
not acceptable repercussions in a
liberal society but if you mean by
repercussions
criticism ridicule uh that kind of thing
in other words more speech in response
to your speech even protest in response
to your speech then uh
of course you have absolutely no right
because when people protest against your
form of speech that they're exercising
their own free speech so that is
absolutely fine as well yeah i think
it's
actually quite simple this point but
this is a point that is missed all the
time
it's really straightforward in in a in a
liberal system liberal society this is
something
that has been completely overlooked
anyone should be able to say whatever
they want
uh and then people are able to say what
they want in turn
in response and that's how that's how it
should work so when you hear um
particularly writers for the guardian
talking about how the thing is when
people talk about free speech what they
really mean is they want consequence
free speech
for start no one has ever said that i
mean literally no one has ever st
that so this is an incredible it's not
even so much of a straw man it's too
insubstantial even to be made of straw
there's literally nobody who comes close
to the invisible man yeah
it's invisible man like no no one has
ever said that
that they want the right to say whatever
they want without someone criticizing
them back no one's ever said that
and if they have then they're deranged
and they're they're we're talking about
a fringe group of people
so that has to be put to rest that that
that over
lie um so no free speech is the right to
say whatever you want and for people to
say whatever they want back to you
why does it matter because it is the
bedrock of a liberal democracy it is the
it is the it is the foundation of all of
our freedoms
there can be no other freedoms any any
progress that has ever been made in
terms of the advancement of personal
liberty and social liberty
has come through the exercise of free
speech of saying what you want
expressing your thoughts
it is the root to personal autonomy if
you can't uh
express what you what you feel about
something then you cannot develop
we cannot innovate without free speech
there can be no innovation there has
never been an innovation without
without the freedom to say what you want
and particularly to say controversial
things that's how innovation happens
you can't reason without speech because
uh the very active reason
is typically a collaborative effort the
the way that we evolve and learn
is through uh uh discussion with other
people and expressing ideas and getting
it wrong and making mistakes and all of
that is part of it
um so it is the linchpin of absolutely
everything that we value if we value
freedom and that's why it is
it is alarming to me that people are so
cavalier about it when you hear a lot of
people online
when they want free speech skeptics i
call them you know when they when they
call it freeze peach
you know that really original pun and
they sometimes have an image of a peach
frozen in an ice cube they say oh look
at you with your freeze peach
for start it's the most unimaginative i
mean you know they should be banned
just for criminal unoriginality right
but they they they say this
stuff um but to be so cavalier about
such a foundational
principle is actually pretty damn
disturbing it's like they don't care and
they don't realize
that they're they are themselves
dependent on
on the on their right to free speech in
order to behave like [ __ ] they they
need to have that right too
um so you know people shouldn't be so
clear about it doesn't free speech allow
those [ __ ] to cause harm and
offense though and other [ __ ] as
well
yeah that's the point they can i'm not
here suggesting again this would be the
interpretation
oh you've just mocked people who use the
phrase freeze
peach uh and therefore you're trying to
shut them down aren't you trying to
silence them you're trying to sense them
no
criticism is not the same as censorship
i i often think that people who mistake
the two must be doing so willfully they
have to be i mean how else could they
you know everyone knows this um so i
often get that as well like if i've when
i've mocked things in the past
um people have said about why are you
having to go there i thought you
i thought you cared about free speech i
always get this all the time it's like
yeah
i'm exercising my free speech to
criticize what they said
that's kind of how it works and they can
do it back to me that's fine it's okay
i i think one of the reasons i wrote the
book is fundamentally
there are so many misconceptions around
around free speech that
uh so many basic misconceptions you know
that really people should have learned
about
a long time ago and and you're always
having to fend them off
and i'd just like to put those things to
rest and i think i think people
need to have uh a a a sort of more
sensible conception of what is meant
by the concept of free speech and so
most of the arguments around this topic
are dealing with straw men and
they're dealing with misconceptions and
so if you can just get beyond all that
detritus then we can have a discussion
about the actual issues because there
are some very difficult issues
surrounding the topic
but we're not going to get anywhere if
people don't know what free speech means
so that's one of the reasons i wanted to
i i learned
about ethics and meta ethics from a
buddy who's at
oxford uni and i'd never learned this
before and what you told me was that
if you have two people trying to debate
ethics who
disagree on meta ethics the ethical
discussion actually breaks down because
the underlying principles that they're
coming to the table holding
don't support any sort of discussion on
top of that and it seems like
you're trying to sort of do this here
like look this is the battleground that
we're supposedly playing on
yeah we can now have a conversation any
kind of either productive or
unproductive but at least we can have a
conversation
because we know the rules of the game
it's exactly right
and actually i've been wrestling with
this issue for a while now is is how do
you
argue against those who are incapable of
argument
this is really hard because i'm all for
i think we need more discussion not less
i think
i think one of the major problems that i
think i've said it to you before one of
the major problems that we face at the
moment is people aren't talking to each
other people from opposing political
ideas
they're not they're not sitting down and
talk to each other so i'm all for doing
that and i will always do that but
if someone comes into the room and wants
to talk but they're not going to use
play by the rules right
in other words they're going to just
throw insults in other words they're
going to start guessing what they think
you believe
right which is something they always do
uh they're going to misrepresent your
perspective in other words they're just
arguing with a version of themselves
that they've created
if they're going to do that then that's
that's bad faith you can't you can't
actually argue with someone like that
and i think
i think it's really important when it
comes to argument
uh that yes you make an effort you may
go out your way to talk to people who
disagree with you
but if they are unwilling or incapable
of argumentation
then don't bother and block them i i
seriously mean i think i think and you
might say well you're creating an echo
chamber well look
someone comes in and says there are 32
letters in the alphabet
let's debate well i'm not going to
debate that person because
you know it's clearly not the case and
if they absolutely refuse to accept the
basic premise
you can't go you just can't go any
further than that i had this the other
day where someone on twitter was on me
saying um
nobody oh you're saying everyone in this
country just accepts that uh
or just uses they all the time as a
singular pronoun
right we'd already passed the point of
you know where you do if you don't know
this the gender of the
person uh and that's something that's a
colloquial form of the term they
but the idea that the vast majority of
people do not understand they as a
plural pronoun is simply not true and
the only way you would think that that
is the case is if you don't know people
or if you're being willfully obtuse in
order to to to win the argument so
therefore i'm not going to debate that
person
you have to accept certain premises in
order to move on
one of them is just knowing how to argue
why is it mostly people on the right
who seem to be promoting freedom of
speech that we rarely hear
the left complain about lacking free
speech
well uh the opposite was true when i was
a child so
uh this is this is something that i
think shows us that it's not a part of
that issue you know when i was a kid
they used to be i mean you're too young
but there were things like uh
the daily mail and the daily express i
think tried to
had a campaign to try and ban david
cronenberg's film crash
uh there were um all sorts of campaigns
every now and then whenever there was i
mean
it go back even before my time there
were campaigns against things like the
last temptation of christ the scorsese
film
or las tango in paris um so there's
always these sort of
centaurus kind of campaigns going on and
say that we should ban artistic
expression of one form
or another but it was always coming from
the right when i was a kid it was always
i mean you just associated i mean then
if you think of mary whitehouse who was
the famous campaigner
who did the cleanup tv campaign back in
the uh the 60s and 70s and then
the video nasties campaign in the 80s
you know in the 80s they banned films
like driller killer
and um evil dead was banned you know the
sam raimi film
uh that was that was banned by the uh by
the video nasties
uh scandal uh and all of this was coming
from the right this was just the way
that because because conservatives
traditionally have a sort of
i suppose a kind of uh old-fashioned
view of of decorum and that kind of
thing
and they and but they all bought into
this myth
uh which was very much mary whitehouse's
thing that uh popular entertainment has
the capacity to corrupt the masses
and it was it was a kind of very
snobbish idea that basically suggested
that poor people
were like robots who just do what they
you know they just see stuff and they
react okay
um that exact philosophy and idea is now
predominantly expressed by those on the
left it's a weird shift
it's difficult to determine when exactly
it happened but you'll notice that all
all calls for sort of artistic
censorship or criticism which is saying
well why hasn't this film uh got more
diversity or representational why
why is why is this film sending a
negative message about women or a
negative message about
about gay people or whatever it might be
and when of course the role of art
it has absolutely nothing to do with
messages or morality uh necessarily not
not that
art can't have a moral message if it
wants to but it always puts me off when
it does i find it quite reverberative
as a as a form but you know um this is
now coming
always from the guardian always from the
new states but always from the leftist
publication this is just where it is now
um this very haughty puritanical
approach uh these
this pearl clutching would be the the
phrase
it's a very good phrase is it because
you really imagine people go oh you know
you know very camp very kind of oh this
person sets up this rude
disgusting thing um it's just shifted
and it will no doubt shift back again
you know uh every now and then you get
it from the right
even now you do you get it when when
when certain uh creative people do
something that is considered offensive
and you'll get that and that will always
happen
it's just it's just a strange phenomenon
that at the moment
uh the the ones who would seek to shut
down forms of expression
tend to be on the left and of course
that is largely down to the new social
justice movement which mistrusts
at its heart mistrusts speech and sees
speech
as violence and conflates the two things
uh
and pretty much everyone within that
camp i mean there are there are
disagreements along the way but
pretty much everyone is of the view that
language has the capacity to
normalize behavior and and that people
do follow these mechanical cues from
these mechanical linguistic cues um and
ultimately that's down to a mistrust of
humanity and particularly a mistrust of
working-class people that's what you'll
find which is why they often go after
working-class comics uh because
it's the audiences that are dangerous
they won't go after a middle-class comic
talking about various things because you
know they're better educated audience
they understand what they do you know
it's
there is a deep snap very patronizing
isn't it it's sort of odd incredible
paternalistic like kind of overbearing
like nannies like neo-nanny state
in a really bizarre way there was an
article
uh when the dapper laughs you remember
the dapper last controversy
i have absolutely no idea but they
succeeded in having his tv show booted
off
i think was itv too um and there was a
really alarmist
ludicrous article online talking about
how his show was a rapist
almanac they used i don't think they
used that word right correctly
but it was absolutely insane and um
actually the whole article was hilarious
because he'd obviously gone through his
thesaurus and just tried to sound as
learned as possible but actually by
doing so came across as incredibly
unlettered
um but but when he um wrote this article
and people but it wasn't just that he
wrote i mean you can have some maniacs
writing articles about this sort of
stuff but
so many people bought into it and even
comedians i know
signed this open letter saying we should
have this band it was a it was a weird
moment although
i have to say some of those who i know
who did that now
uh regret it um but of course the it was
really because dapa last audience were
working class
and this idea that they would watch him
picking up girls and being
being a cheeky lad or whatever i mean
look it's not to my taste i don't i
don't even know what it was right i
watched a bit of it and i thought
it's not for me you know but but i don't
think for a second
that some working-class guys are gonna
watch it and think all right i've got
permission now to go out and commit some
sexual assault
incredible incredible this this it is
just patronizing isn't it
it is just a fear of of of people who
aren't like you
it's it's because believe it or not it
doesn't matter what class you come from
everyone knows the difference between a
joke and real life
and even if it were an outright
instruction to behave badly
people don't people do have agency they
do make decisions you know
they don't just do things because
someone tells them but this is
a belief that you can't actually we
can't get over because it's
so ingrained now it's everywhere you
know it comes down to even
in parliament when boris johnson was
using the metaphor of the surrender bill
and you had all these labour mps saying
that your language is normalizing
violence
people are going to hear you using
military metaphors well politic
political language is full of military
metaphors
conflict we we go on to fight we need
strength all of this sort of stuff but
it's interpreted as
incitement right well again this is
based on a very patronizing view
of humanity it's not true
you